tom brady's seventh super bowl victory
the goat broke his own record for the
most wins ever
i think we knew this was going to happen
tonight didn't we so howdy celebrate
tom shared his moment in the spotlight
with his three kids
eight-year-old vivian and
eleven-year-old benjamin were there with
mom giselle
13 year old jack was there too his mom
bridget moynihan congratulated her ex
on the gram they started off about this
big and now look at him so i'm
trying to stop the little clock right
now but it'd be nice to celebrate with
them too
fans couldn't help but notice that the
43 year old quarterback seems to have
stopped the clock on his own aging
calling out the benjamin buttoning of
brady with memes like these
so how does he do it tom works out at
least three hours a day
and sticks to a super strict no caffeine
no white sugar diet
there's more to come as far as football
yeah we're coming back
[Music]
also celebrating last night tom's
teammate rob gronkowski
and his girlfriend our special
correspondent camille costig who made
this call
with us on friday yes the grog and now
i'm predicting two touchdown passes from
tom this game
camille gave us a first-hand look at the
festivities on the field
congratulating her man and celebrating
with gronk's brothers just minutes after
the bucks win
today they're at the happiest place on
earth we made it to disney
wrong family rolling deep while the
chief's loss patrick mahomes fiance
brittany matthews is still celebrating
she's seven months pregnant and posted
this sweet message to the dad to be
not how we wanted it to end but forever
proud of him
now let's have a baby what's up bt i am
kayla nicole
it's minutes away from game time i'm so
excited
and kansas city's travis kelsey had his
girlfriend on camera host kayla nicole
they're supporting him win or
the trophy but lose all good